hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
here's a fun viral algebra problem that
many people requested i solve
if four b squared plus one over b
squared is equal to two
then what is the value of eight b cubed
plus 1 over b cubed
you're not allowed to use calculators
and you have to solve this in 90 seconds
i admit i wasn't able to solve it that
quickly
pause the video right now if you'd like
to give it a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video to check your answer or to learn
how to solve this problem
[Music]
so in order to solve this algebra
problem we're going to take a detour
into geometry
start with the cube whose side length is
x
the volume of the cube will be x cubed
now take a smaller cube with a side
length of y
its volume will be y cubed
we are now going to derive the
difference of cubes formula
what's the difference in volume of the
larger cube minus the smaller cube
one way to express this volume is x
cubed minus y cubed
we're now going to derive another way to
express this volume it will be the sum
of the volume of three rectangular
prisms
here's one rectangular prism
its dimensions are x x and x minus y
so its volume will be x squared
multiplied by the quantity x minus y
we now solve for the volume of a
different rectangular prism
we write its dimensions and then
multiply them together to get the volume
we add that to the previous volume
we have one more rectangular prism
we finally calculate its volume
we've now figured out two ways of
expressing the same volume
notice that each of the terms has a
factor of x minus y
we can factor this out and we end up
with the following formula
x cubed minus y cubed is equal to the
quantity x minus y multiplied by the
quantity x squared plus x times y plus y
squared
that's the difference of cubes formula
now we can get the sum of cubes formula
with a little bit of a trick
we start out with the difference of
cubes formula and then we let y equal
negative z
we substitute in negative z wherever we
see the variable y
we then simplify this formula and we end
up with the sum of cubes formula
it'll be the sum of cubes formula we
need to solve this problem
notice that 8b cubed plus one over b
cubed is a sum of cubes
we'll let x equal two b and z equal one
over b
we now use our formula and we get the
following product
to simplify this notice that we know
that four b squared plus one over b
squared is equal to two
therefore in the second factor we have
four b squared plus one over b squared
and we can substitute in two
this then simplifies to be two minus two
which is equal to zero and then zero
times anything is equal to zero
and that's our answer apq plus one over
b cubed is equal to zero
with the sum of cubes formula we can
solve this problem in no time at all
incredible
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]